a lot of familiar faces out there but
for the few who don't know me I'm
Michael Doula I'm the chief technology
officer here at yell libraries uh I'm
very pleased to be introducing our next
speaker David germano uh from the
University of Virginia where he's a
professor of the Department of religious
studies um a little extra please because
UVA is my own Graduate School alma moer
I started out there many years ago as a
as a as a humanist myself uh and then I
became a technologist and been sort of
uh waffling back and forth between the
two ever since um UVA is a uh one of the
Pioneers I would say in this area I
remember back in the early 90s when the
institute for advanced technology in the
humanities started up there iath and I
was uh moved on from my academic career
at that time and working in technology
in California and I I saw that and I
thought hm maybe I should move back to
Virginia uh it looked pretty interesting
uh I didn't do it but I did eventually
find my way back into Academia by
another route um and back to the east
coast now now here at Yale so UVA is is
a long player in this game um David is
co-director of the Tibet Center uh at
University of Virginia and is also um
director of Shanti which stands for
Sciences Humanities and the Arts Network
of technological initiatives um so I'm
certainly curious to find out what
exactly that does how it differs from
some earlier Ventures such as aath uh
which we're all familiar with uh he's
also editor of the Journal of the
International Association of Tibetan
studies uh founder and director of the
Tibetan and Himalayan life Library the
largest International initiative using
digital technology to facilitate
collaboration in tibetan studies across
disciplines and my understanding he's
going to talk a little bit about some of
the problems uh involved in moving from
this array of thousands of interesting
cool digital projects um to how do we
systematize them a little bit which is
certainly something that we're dealing
with here at Yale and I think is is a
common issue across the digital
Humanities um so without further Ado I
will turn things over to
David
so thanks so much for the opportunity to
talk with you today and especially to
Susan and Mark and Beth and all the
others involved in organizing this event
so as you heard my original home is in a
religious studies department and so
although I myself am actually not a
particularly religious person it's kind
of worn off over the years so I'm going
to offer you a cosmogeny and eschatology
and my personal story of Salvation
through digital technology in between so
I want to offer you a few apologies in
advance just to limit your expectations
which is I'm not going to be expire
inspiring or exciting and uh I'll tell
you a little bit why uh because one of
the things I realized over the course of
my 20 years at the University of
Virginia is that salvation cannot be an
individual Affair it's a collective
Affair and what that means is that I
spend a lot of my life now thinking
about things that I probably would have
committed suicide about 20 years ago
which is Comm Community formation
institutional um building organizational
behavior and kind of the plumbing social
plumbing and Technical Plumbing of how
you fashion solutions to these areas and
finally I want to apologize for being a
little bit negative about the idea and
concept of digital Humanities as I joked
with Beth when we were coming over for
me and I think the University of
Virginia overall it's been like 20 years
in digital Humanities and so it's not
really like a exciting sexy kind of
romance it's more like a marriage that's
a little bit in crisis so um what I want
to talk about today is in the space of
that kind of inspiration fatigue uh kind
of being fatigued with being inspiring
kind of thinking more about the
nitty-gritty detail of how do you
fashion Sustainable Solutions to complex
problems so against that background I
had this grandiose uh title of going
Beyond digital Humanities so I'm going
to start by just giving you a slide and
a little bit of orientation about my own
situatedness within this field or this
idea this activity and so forth
and just give you my personal story in
from 1996 until 2013 today to start in
1996 I'm actually not sure about that
date I just kind of guessed about it my
personal details are a little bit fuzzy
but somewhere around there I joined
camlot digital camlot which was the
institute for advanced technology in
Humanities and they had I think they had
a round table now actually I'm not quite
sure anymore I I think it was a round
table although it might have been square
but probably it was round and around
that Round Table sat fellows what we
called fellows and aath really kind of
pioneered this notion of digital
Humanities fellows and so every week we
would get together our my graduate
students myself as faculty and these
digital technologists in particularly
worthy Martin from the computer science
department and Daniel pity from ith and
we'd talk about these things talk about
these intellectual concerns and talk
about technology and try to find some
medium transformative point where
technology would change and intellectual
concerns and research would change and
so forth and we would do that week after
week week after week after week um it
was sometimes really inspiring sometimes
really frustrating but the basic model
was of the chosen one or the chosen two
there were very few fellows and fellows
kind of accumulated over the years but
basically every year they would choose
one fellow maybe there'd be an associate
fellow as well so it was a tremendous
amount of investment in a very small
number of people doing high-end Elite
kind of research activity and we used to
call it in those days the texto crcy
when John unsworth was there and so
forth not to accuse John of being a
techrat but there was this kind of
access of people in The English
Department and history Department who
were working very heavily with text and
that was really a kind of dominant focus
and we were all interested in this idea
of thematic research archives take some
kind of particular theme maybe it's
Rosetti with Jerry McAn or the um civil
war with Ed SS or for myself it was
Tibet and and build a research archive
around this of disparate kinds of
materials hopefully and theoretically
including analytical and interpretive
resources in 1998 I remember as I
started with one of those ttrac things
since I myself was a texr for sure long
history of working with Buddhist
scripture and Buddhist literature and
wanted to build a thematic research
archive take an uncataloged big
scriptural Cannon of Tibetan Buddhist
literature and build a what we thought
of as an Innovative catalog for this
that could operate as a front end to
access the text and scholarship and
translations and so forth and one of the
things one of the journeys I kind of got
set off in back then was the going from
kind of text to cont text and we had
this thing called Authority files which
I'm sure all of you in the library know
what an authority file is it was like so
there's places mentioned in the copons
and people's names and so forth and
terms we had to translate so we created
all these kind of uh Authority files
where you'd say okay this place name and
here's where it occurs and so forth this
technical term here's how we translate
it and we try to do things like
disambiguate because the same place uh
same place name might be used for
several different places and the reason
these were absurd Authority files
because I went way off the deep end and
so from for example the one Authority
file of just simple place names to try
to disambiguate places referred to in
Califon saying this text was translated
in this place and so forth we developed
an extraordinarily elaborate gazeteer
structure that just went uh in very
elaborate fashion different toponyms and
locations and so forth so these
Authority files became the nucleus of
very complex expensive projects in their
own right and so we began to explore the
the kind of um
context of text which then became
projects in their own right places and
people and organizations and so forth in
1999 set off on a a journey to try to
figure out about orality we began to
think about the challenge of how do you
take oral knowledge which is so
important in my part of the world tobet
and try to make that subject to the same
kind of analytical processes and
representations that we enjoy with text
and I'll briefly show you some of the
work we've done there at trying to take
audio video speech and make it available
to people in analytical ways like we do
with with text then I remember in 2000
Fedora which I'm not sure I can say
anymore flexible extensible digital
object repository architecture still
remember it after all these years
started off at the University of
Virginia with thorney staples and the
University of Virginia library opened up
this department the digital library
research and development department and
that filled my mind with dreams of
integration that I could take my place
files and my text files and my audio
video materials and mash them all up
into some absolutely unbelievable thing
little did I know that after all these
years I'm still not using Fedora but
anyways that's another story um 2001
Thorne Staples who was the the kind of
poet and architect of Fedora back then
he was talking about the human or the
social or the political body of Fedora
which he called information communities
and I had the bright idea that I could
be an information Community about Tibet
and I could weave people together around
the world using this technology tools
people and Collections and so forth and
so we tried to create an information
community at the University of Virginia
they actually authorized the position
and then one of those damn crashes came
and they canel the search and I never
got my information Community anyways
what what to say 2006 we've been
building a lot of different tools a lot
of different systems trying to work with
Tibet audio video materials spatial data
photographs accumulating huge amounts of
materials lots of collaborations and so
forth and I had the sense that I was
building one of these horrible Egyptian
Pyramids where I was breaking the body
of our graduate students and myself
against the um like slave labor you know
and the whole thing was absolutely
inaccessible and it was like I remember
my C CIO of the dep CIO of the
University of Virginia James Hilton once
was describing a project he he does
called Deep and about preservation and
he called it the roach motel because
things just go in but they never come
out so I started to feel that way about
the Tibetan and himan Library like a
massive roach Hotel kind of pyramid so
he began to turn to the idea of services
or web services in the sense that we're
not just building a destination in the
web but like many of us are now thinking
instead we're building informational
service and people could take these
services and use them in different kinds
of ways and finally I get to 2008 and I
realize digital Humanities is
impossible and why was it impossible I
remember back in 1998 when we were doing
the Absurd Authority files that Daniel
pity who's a very good friend at ath he
got really frustrated with me one day
and he said you know David you're only
going to accomplish this if you raise
like half a million dollars and involve
hundreds of people and that was his way
of saying would you stop it you know
leave me alone so well I raised half a
million dollars a year for 12 13 years
and I involved hundreds of people and in
2008 I still was completely
unsustainable and so I began to think
you know this is not working I can't
keep raising more money I can't involve
more hundreds of people because I can't
as an individual create a sustainable
infrastructure for these kinds of
projects it's got to be a collective
Enterprise and so we found ourselves at
a Crossroads in 2009 I myself did the
University of Virginia did and that's
where I'm going to turn to
now so July 2009 an improbable mandate
for Change and so basically we at the
University felt hey we've been doing
this for a long time we have a
distinguished past but now everybody's
talking about digital Humanities they
want to have sex with our you know
spouse and but it's our spouse but we're
not doing anything exciting anymore so
our spouse is getting bored with us so
what are we going to do so we have an
uncertain future distinguished past we
don't want to become like dispossess
Aristocrats or everybody's like oh you
guys were so inspiring but you should
buy a new suit or something you know so
we had a series of meetings convened by
the CIO of the University of Virginia
and the librarian Karen Wittenberg and
James Hilton and they brought together
faculty to say hey what do you want to
do next what can you do how can we
reinvent ourselves where's digital
Humanities going and so the board of
visitors out of all those conversations
funded this thing called Shanti um for
mainstreaming whatever that was supposed
to mean and the idea was was really
quite exciting that Central it and the
library were going to take their funds
their actual core programming funds and
put it into something that faculty would
govern over me me being a faculty member
and the governing board and so forth and
we had a what I thought was a mission
improbable because the faculty who kind
of met together for a year to figure out
what they would do next came up with
something that looked a lot like if it
involved a lot of projects and Elite
faculty activity and so forth and when
the board of visitors gave this money um
they said here's the money great go
forward and by the way don't do what you
guys said you were going to do at that
point many of my friends departed
because you know and I was left standing
um I guess I didn't move back fast
enough and they basically the improbable
aspect of the mission was here's 36
months no guarantee of a future beyond
that here's a super tight budget um by
the way don't do fellows don't do
projects total antipathy towards fellows
and projects um which was mysterious to
us faculty because all we knew was
fellows and projects and also have a
huge impact which meant
thousands okay and no details so that
was our mandate it was a mandate for
change but no details about how we would
accomplish that change and so the story
I want to tell you today is kind of what
we've done over the past three years in
terms of thinking about this Collective
challenge of what you do after 20 years
of work in digital Humanities and figure
out doesn't look a whole lot of
sustainability is in the offing so um I
thought about this at this point is I
used to give inspiring talks like Tony
Robbins of digital Humanities and so
forth but I I got in fatigued with my
inspiring because I felt it was like
marching lemings off the cliff you know
how limings are supposedly supposed to
behave they March to the cliff and then
in Mass they just go off the cliff so I
felt I could give all these great talks
about digital Humanities and F go oh
that's great that's incredible what do I
do next and I just push him off the
cliff because I'd already been down that
cliff and I've been falling for many
years so now I later learned out that
lming don't jump off the cliff Disney
like threw them off the cliff in order
to make this kind of famous movie where
LeMans were going off the cliff I think
Disney had like like catapults and they
threw them off the cliff and killed them
so anyways that I learned that later so
that was another um kind of ironic
aspect to the whole notion of limings so
digital Humanities in some sense to
continue the you know aquatic metaphors
a red herin and I'm going to tell you
why I think digital Humanities um at
some level is a a slightly problematic
way to go
um and one aspect that we heard a little
bit about this morning is that
originally with digital Humanities there
was a lot of scolly digital projects
that were engaged in repetitive
collection infrastructure building they'
build um kind of infrastructure to
manage their Collections and often never
really arriving at data analysis and
interpretation another big challenge we
face in the humanities is that people
often uh lack basic digital literacy
they use email sure they they use visual
resources they look up things on the web
and after that they're kind of clueless
now as it turns out I work across all 11
schools the University of Virginia a lot
of people not just humanists lack basic
digital literacy but that's a another
story so how do we get to sustainability
technical sustainability human
sustainability how do we have bir
Direction bidirectional scalability not
just scaling up but scaling down how do
you take a small modest project you can
get going really rapidly for your
research and teaching and then scale it
up to something very complex in a
sustainable way without a huge
investment of Grants and sacrifice of
your personal career but then also once
you get up to this level how do you
scale it back down I want to take two or
three years off I want to do something
else with my life how does my stuff get
carried along so that I can scale down
and scale up like an accordion so I
think of that as bidirectional
scalability and a key part of the
solution it's what we've been working on
for the past couple years is a service
oriented digital ecology which I'll tell
you a little bit about what we've done
and uh so the challenge of sustainable
scholarly websites how do we create the
universities the research one
universities like Yale and University of
Virginia and elsewhere a kind of um
infrastructure of across the board that
would allow people to create scholarly
websites that are both simple and
complex and move up and down um the
scale and so a spectrum of different
kinds of websites faculty want to
produce community building things that
are more like random access cataloges
maybe it's a bunch of photographs or a
bunch of um videos some more media
specific maybe it's structured reference
resource is like a dictionary or
encyclopedia maybe it's more of like a
Blog news theer maybe it's like the
curated thematic research collections
that we've been talking about for so
long in digital Humanities and how do we
enable faculty to do this in a way
that's scalable and is project free
because no one wants the projects
because the projects come with the whole
human cost of how do you pay for them
how do you sustain them the
customizability of it the idiosyncratic
character of it and so
forth so these are just some famous
thematic research collections developed
to the University of Virginia with the
sponsorship of the institute for
advanced technology and Humanities and
University of Virginia library the
Rosetti archive with Jerry McAn focused
on a particular person and his Corpus
and artwork and so forth the Valley of
the Shadows with ED air all about a
particular set of communities in the
American Civil War and letters Diaries
official records battle maps interactive
maps and so forth um the Salem
Witchcraft Trials by Ben Ray taking a
particular event or event over a series
of of years and American history and
Gathering Together different kinds of
materials and resources and my own
project the Tibetan Himalayan Library
devoted to a geographical region in the
world over space and time and different
kinds of
media and then just unlike thematic
research collections things that are
more you know news oriented uh sorry I
apologized someone already about Paul
Ryan that was before the last year or so
but anyways um at imy religious
dispatches more of a Blog news oriented
site but very scholarly in orientation
so Just A Brief Review of different
kinds of websites that we create in the
academy and how could we make these work
in a way that is more sustainable so
where were we in 2009 when we started
well first of all we are very typical
all the money goes to HR fiscal systems
and student systems and then basic
infrastructure wireless access Etc
almost nothing goes into scholarly
technology that's our problem we don't
have money and we don't have Staffing in
the core thing that we're actually
supposed to be at the university the
money is somewhere else it's in Oracle
it's in people soft it's in the things
that are important for the University to
run but they're not addressing the
central challenge of teaching and
research so that's where we began and so
they that was their little small tight
budget in 36 months they gave to us that
was the gesture okay do it you know do
it do it go go go so who are the players
Central it and Central it has a lot of
different organizational units and the
problem is these players are not playing
together and fashioning those
relationships is something that involves
not technology but the hard work of kind
of political alliances and Community
formation so Central it you've got
Enterprise infrastructure maybe you have
the people running the learning
management system you have the people
doing customized application support the
people running the server Farms etc etc
school it shops often you have it shops
that are school specific we have Central
it and we also have it shops in the
Health Sciences and business and so
forth that are pretty much independent
different kinds of Library units we had
a lot of Library units in the past and
they've slowly Consolidated into a
smaller array of things University
Communications may seem an odd one there
but very important player they're the
ones responsible for forward-facing you
know web presence for departments and
schools and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about what we've been doing
with them digital Humanities centers of
various types which the University of
Virginia like spawns them you can't walk
across campus without tripping over one
you know so thematic centers of
different kinds that may have digital
interest us but they're first and
foremost thematically oriented and then
of course the
Press so what's with scholarly it well
first of all you have the learning
management system which I'm going to
come back to because I've spent a lot of
my life on learning management systems
and I can only call them lamentable so
um I was early on warned by the cio's
office like stop talking that way but
here I am at yell so I can say whatever
I want to so back at the University of
Virginia I'm effectively muzzled I have
to be very careful about what I say so
local licenses we have local licenses
site licenses for things like arcgis or
whatever it might be and then you have
brittle technology otherwise known as
technology that breaks you know digital
Humanity specializes in creating brittle
technology technology that doesn't scale
technology that breaks to the moment you
I've done a lot of brittle technology I
specialize in designing brittle
technology 2009 no damps no digital
asset management system at the
University of Virginia you're a faculty
you've got photographs you've got audio
video you've got text we've got no
solutions for you at
all okay you could go into some
particular Center like digital
Humanities Center or Library unit and
maybe they'll build you something like
just for you an audio video management
system who would have thought I mean how
exciting well not exciting at all it's
brittle it breaks so no CMS no CMS no
content management system for creating
websites whatsoever I did a survey in
2009 of every one of our 11 schools and
I found out everyone had a different
solution and that solution was for their
departmental and school websites not
extended to The Faculty so faculty had
no content managements before creating
websites no online management of spatial
data no way to form easy structured data
no way to create online visualizations
no way to document culturally networked
information people place events and
subjects and impossible to maintain and
completely detach departmental websites
supported by University
communication that's where we were just
three years ago
and finally the whole fetish of digital
Humanities that somehow intellectuals in
the humanities are idiosyncratic and so
they need idiosyncratic technology
that's garbage I don't know how many
times I've heard that and it's simply
not
true I can say that since I'm one of
those idiosyncratic intellectuals so
March 2013 today where are we what have
we been doing so over three or four
three and a half years we fashioned
relationships with University
Communications different organizational
units within Central it the library
digital Humanities centers and so forth
and we've built together the basis for
digital ecology that we think can form a
sustainable um infrastructure for people
to begin to create the kinds of things
that we used to create in digital
Humanity centers but do so without
funding without customization and be
able to focus more on their analytical
interpretive agendas as we heard this
morning so first layer is collecting
collecting managing your media and so
we've um are kind of trying to integrate
sh shared shelf as a photographic
management system we've been building
out something in Drupal for managing
audio video including Rich time encoded
transcripts Confluence as a as an
Enterprise Wiki for dealing with text
and then structuring how do faculty
create easy structured data and easy
structured data does not mean a mySQL
postgress database that is not easy for
a humanist and so what does easy
structured data look like and then we
built this application for managing a
particular kind of structured data which
we called knowledge maps for people who
want to document people places events
and subjects and we had so many people
humanists walking into our office who
basically wanted to manage data about
people places events and subjects and
express their inter connections now how
do you synthesize these things Sher
chelf and the and the cultur solution
they have nothing to do with each other
in general now they've been talking to
each other lately but that's a separate
issue so how do you synthesize across
different repositories how do you
connect these repositories together when
they have their own provenance and their
own technology and so we've been
building knowledge indexing services we
outsourced semantic uh indexing of
assets we outsourced Geor referencing of
assets and then use those knowledge
services to index different kinds of
things to express interconnections
across various media collections
visualizing I'll briefly show you a
project called Shiva which is stands for
Shanti interactive visualization
applications I think and this is an
attempt to basically mainstream
visualization so charts Maps time L
networks videos Etc create an easy way
that any faculty member can take these
things and within the space of an
afternoon begin to create complex
visualizations which can scale up to
extremely complex
things um collaborating as learning
management system stuff I'll talk about
in a couple of minutes publishing how do
people then take the collections and the
structured data and synthesiz together
and the visualizations and how do they
publish them and so we've rolled out
several different content management
system systems one being WordPress one
being Drupal and then other things I
won't talk about today we're trying to
revisit the issue of the discussion form
one of the most tired and tedious and
unhelpful things that's out there in the
realm of academic technology and think
about that in a new way um networking
enabling Technologies of various kinds
and then different kinds of specialized
functions Unity for Virtual Worlds uh
juxa that's been developed by nines and
we've done some support and help and so
on and so forth okay so collecting the
challenge is about faculty what we call
Wild digital assets wild because faculty
are wild they're not domesticated
they're not part of the library and so
how do you deal with those wild digital
assets their audio video their
photographs their text and so forth and
how do you preserve manage and deliver
them we were doing a really bad job of
this um four years ago and so he wanted
to create like One-Stop repositories so
you could go one place and across your
different projects and different people
and different groups they could manage
those assets those photographs those
videos and so forth and also at least
putting aside the fact of how you might
want to use these in different places
that there'd be a One-Stop place to see
all of the University of Virginia's
faculty photographs and text and videos
um in addition to being able to use them
through web services in your own website
in flexible and modular ways so we
adopted shared shelf for photographs
we've been rolling that out across the
university we began to build something
we call Media base and Drupal using
cultur for audio video including
transcripts for text a broad variety of
solutions much more complex challenge
than audio video and photograph
photographs and so we've been exploring
Confluence we've been using Drupal in
different ways and you know text have
blogs and wik like information long form
essays editions of text so much more
challenging thing and in order to use
these things that we store in these
collections into different websites and
Pages there's obvious solution which is
just take an embed code and you can
embed it into your website but you know
I have immodest kind of goals because I
come from a religious studies department
so I like like ultimate salvation I'm so
sick of embed codes what do you do with
an embed code you embed and that's it
what about when you want functionality
like you have all this cool
functionality over here in your audio
video system but all you can do is embed
your stupid audio video on your own
website well I'd like that functionality
on my own website so how do you go
beyond simply embedding and take content
analytical searches uh functionality and
embed that into your website so that you
can truly have your your pie and eat it
too or cut your pie I don't know what
that means so another challenge how do
you travel across repository borders so
collecting now I got to go really fast
through these things I have way too many
slides I started adding them this
morning so I started adding a lot of
illustrations here's just the Audio
Video Collection we build it within
Drupal around this cultur toolkit and so
forth and just to show you a special
thing we buil into it which is the
capacity to search the the speech
content and so we have different methods
to create uh time-coded Rich
multilingual transcripts I did a search
of the word for dream and it searched
across all these audio videos and
produce the outcome the red shows you
where does that word occur in those
different videos and now I click on one
of the search results and it brings up
the video to that point where the word
dream occurs and the yellow is
highlighting the word where the dream
occurs and I can click on any of those
lines and play it or I can just have it
play naturally it automatically Scrolls
and I can also see the transcript in
various ways instead of seeing a
transcript to the right I can pass it
into speech bubbles I can change the
languages between whatever I have
translated to in this case Tibetan
English and Chinese and the search
results can be shown down below so
multiple flexible ways of dealing with
these transcripts it just shows a way if
we invest as a community in audio video
we can do things that are geared towards
our particular um academic uh uses and
so oops
sorry let me come back to that one real
briefly um so here I did a search in
tibetan for the word tomb like a tomb of
an emperor and I got all the different
audio videos only show one page here and
the red shows where the word tomb or
Bongo occurs in all those audio videos
then I choose one of the search results
and up comes a oral lecture on the site
of the valley of Kings in southern Tibet
where he's talking about all the tombs
and the yellow highlight shows you
exactly where it occurs so all this is
just showing the way in which we're
trying to make audio video open up to
those analytical uses that we've all
been accustomed to in terms of text and
I don't think I have a time to show
these screenshots so I'm just going to
screencast I'll just go through this
this just shows one where I did a search
on the word for boat and it brought up a
bunch of results and one of them I
clicked on was a reading by probably the
most famous modern poet of Tibet um
where he's got this thing called will
this ship take me to the other side
and you just click
on and you can just review the search
results for
that and I have to skip through the rest
but you can see same thing you can
change the languages you can click on
lines and play them and make speech
bubbles and
so
okay and uh I'm just going to talk about
this for a second and terminate it this
is just showing the way in which once
you have this facility we built this
Rich historical dictionary um
application that allows people to build
very detailed historical studies of
words including passages but then we're
also connecting this to the text and to
the videos so that people can search
from the dictionary across both of those
corpuses simultaneously um they can
search across the body of literary text
and across the transcripts of oral
speech and you can begin to dynamically
see how a given word is used both in the
textual corpora as well as the corpora
of different kinds of audio video um you
know speech recordings okay so to go
away from collections I only have 11
minutes left easy structure data so the
challenge is how do we work with
humanists to basically allow them to
structure data then they can use that
structured data in a variety of ways and
so we've been working with Google
spreadsheets rows and columns if you
can't understand that what else can I
say but we've also been looking at other
things um in Drupal CSV and so forth the
idea is just a very simple way to take a
book and with 10 minutes of training
enable a graduate student a faculty
member to begin to uh break that apart
and to structure data store it someplace
that can then be used in our broader
digital ecology and I'll show you
examples of our use for that what about
culturally networked information we
built something in Ruby on Rails called
the knowledge Maps which has extremely
granular kinds of information to deal
with the problems of names you have
place names multiple toponyms how are
the toponyms related to each other
across language and across time to deal
with relationships relationships between
places relationships between people
relationships to organizations typing
them uh Geo referencing them making
semantic extensions and taking every
little bit of information and dating it
and annotating it and sourcing it and so
forth as well as allowing essays and
then for subjects we have Network
visualizations that were now put out
there for places mapping visualizations
events timelines and so forth
so now uh I'm going to show you an
example in just one moment of this but
now how do we take these things and use
them as indexing services to address the
issue of walking across repositories of
taking an audio video repository a
photog photographic repository and
connecting them together even though
they use different Technologies so what
we basically have done is we're taking
those that structured data those
knowledge maps and using them not simply
as a destination where you can go and
get information about places and people
and so forth but also as a synthesizing
service and so people can take whatever
repository they have or collection they
have and they can use the API or the web
service for this to essentially
semantically index those audio videos or
photographs or text or they can Geor
reference it so when you want to say
this text concerns New Haven instead of
typing in the word New Haven what you do
is you basically begin to well you do
type it in you type in New Haven but it
autocompletes through a web service from
this totally external application that
keeps track of all of our toponyms and
once you say you get Five results for
New Haven New Haven Connecticut New
Haven New Jersey New Haven blah blah
blah so you can disambiguate it shows
you some type like this is New Haven the
city this is the New Haven the mountain
whatever and you choose the one you want
and then what it does is it passes the
ID value from the indexing service into
the metadata record then the ID value
through a web service gets a label and
the label could be Chinese or English or
whatever you specify in the application
and it shows that label and then who and
then it um basically hyperlinks it back
to the reference Resource as well as to
all the other assets and other
repositories that have also used that
index in service and so basically we
have outsourced semantic and
geographical indexing and by Outsourcing
it we can use it to bind together
different projects in different
repositories and these can be Community
generated and maintained and so we're in
the process of integrating these with
our content Management systems with
shared shelf with the media base with
the visualization system and so forth
and what we wanted was the same user
friendliness you get from stupid
Facebook tagging but none of the
limitations tagging is wonderful
autocomplete it's mindless you just type
in and there it is and so forth but the
limits of course are that it's typically
not multilingual it's not hierarchical
it's not uh linked to any kind of
semantic content about the CATE ategory
and so we wanted to make all of those
things possible but still have the ease
and convenience of just simply tagging
stuff and also be able to take those um
indexing and add annotations sources
stamp them with times and so forth and
the end result that I'll show you now is
that any service can take the label the
word New Haven or the word exorcism and
Link it back to Associated content
that's coincidence um you know I'm a
Tibetan you know Buddha scholar so back
to Associated content structure data
essays and visualizations so I'll
briefly show you what this looks like
here's um the knowledge maps for
subjects and so I have the problem of I
have a gazeteer I want to index all
those places by feature type so is it a
mountain is it a an aquifer is it a is
it an Empire so I want to build a
feature thesaurus but instead of
building the feature of thesaurus in the
gazeteer I build it outside because I
want to use it for other purposes and so
here we see the top level all the plus
signs can be
expanded and so I can go down to Natural
into water related and get all these
different kinds of water and over on the
left hand side I can add essays and so
forth and you see it says 640 places
that's going through a web service and
asking the gazeteer hey have you used um
this particular uh category of Salt Lake
to index any places and it's also asking
the audio video repository and elsewhere
then if I click on that it goes through
a web service over to the gazeteer and
says here's the 640 assets I have that
have been indexed by that particular ID
value and then I can click on one of
those assets and the gazeteer comes up
dynamically Maps it through a latitude
and longitude just this has relatively
limited information because we
documented all the Salt Lakes but I have
very little to say about them so other
ones have uh many pages of essays in
different languages about them but you
get the point now in addition I can go
to the gazeteer and I can say over there
in feature type in the advanced search I
want to see all the monasteries so when
I type in the word Monastery it
autocompletes from the service from the
web service going back to the knowledge
maps and now when I choose the word
Monastery it goes into the gazeteer and
it pulls up every Monastery there's a
lot in Tibet so there's like um 239 in
the gazeteer right now Tibetan
monasteries and it brings up the place
dictionary entry now all of these
transactions are completely unrelated
appliations that are simply talking to
each other through web services so it's
a service oriented digital ecology and
then it Maps this the monastery brings
up essays you can click on and read and
you can choose other monasteries as
well and
um this is just showing other aspects of
the place dictionary that you can
negotiate you go to back to the
knowledge maps not the place dictionary
it's the place where we keep all of our
index and services go to Township
administrative seat and then you can
again go back and see all the township
administ of seats I think that slide was
out of order and then get different
kinds of information about it okay so
I'm going to skip through all of that
because it's four minutes but oh there
that's the part I wanted to show you so
here's an audio video cataloging record
and so I want to Index this audio video
catalog in that audio video repository
using these knowledge map um services
and so I type in uh I can choose these
different categories of semantic
indexing religious sex or ritual or
historical periods or events or whatever
economics and then I can just type in
the word EXO that's why I said exorcism
it autocompletes through the web service
and then I can choose the one that I
want and it basically passes the ID
value into the metadata for the audio
video asset if I can't find it I can
just browse the entire hierarchy and
figure out why am I not finding exorcism
so here I go into GE geographical
features and nomatic areas of different
kinds and so forth and the same way if I
want to say this video is from Lassa I
type in the word Lassa I hit search it
goes through the API the web service to
the place dictionary it says show me all
the hits for this thing Lassa and tell
me what feature type it is so I can
disambiguate between things with the
same name and when I choose the word l a
city it passes the ID value into the
metadata record goes back there gets a
label and puts it and the end result is
here's the video the metadata says those
are the subject matters the video
concerns and there's the location it's
in Lassa and when I click on the word
Lassa it goes by a web service it
gathers some basic information from the
gazeteer about Lassa and it gathers all
the audio videos that have been indexed
according to Lassa and then I can go and
see the uh Main Place dictionary entry
as well so it's all being tied together
as part of an ecology that different
projects and different people could
theoretically be using oh 2 minutes and
14 seconds
so whoa that sorry that was that was not
intentional
um so visualizing so in my last two or
three minutes visualizing open- Source
visualizations what we wanted to do is
create a way that faculty literally in
one hour with no background could begin
to create structured data and
visualizations so we decided to take a
bunch of Open Source JavaScript
visualization tools and create an
absolutely consistent rapper for it
meaning the interface looks the same for
Google Maps for jit visualizations it's
the same interface for everything drop
down menus you know variables Etc so you
put your stuff in a Google spreadsheet
you log into Drupal you choose whether
you want a chart a timeline a network
visualization a text um we have mapping
where you can really scale it up you can
begin to add KML layers if you have
complex geographical data you want to
deploy um images audio video uh and then
you can begin to annotate all of these
just draw on them you have controls that
you can add so you can add dialogue
boxes and ultimately you can put these
all into a canvas and begin to create
very complex visualizations so I'll
briefly show you what this looks like um
here's the Drupal application you log
into it and shows you different
visualizations people have been
making and that's what every single
visualization looks like now the
visualization tools all have different
provenant different companies different
Origins but they all in our Drupal
application have exactly the same
leftand kind of interface and so when
possible we try to make it drop down
menus or popup if there's more advanced
functionality like you want to query a
big data set and so forth you can do
that that's not going to be a five
minute activity so now if we go from a a
a chart visualization to a mapping
visualization you can see now we're in
Google Maps but it's a completely
consistent interface to that and so
joking remember Herman Kane Godfather's
Pizza with his promise of was 888 or
101010 I call this the 555 project you
know 5 minutes to learn 5 minutes deploy
and 5 minutes to um you know skel in a
different direction so these are just
some very simple things made in 5
minutes they're not complex I wanted to
stick to the whole five minute promise
so here's some data put down data and um
and a spreadsheet then boom you can take
a map and visualize a network of the
University of Virginia and it's um you
know relationships or here's a way to
take uh re georectified historical maps
and place it on Google Earth and so
forth using this application here's a a
timeline where you can take again the
same Google spreadsheets using the same
interface and left hand side and easily
make a a timeline with photographs and
information and so forth charts of
different times um network analysis that
right now it's using jit but we're
probably moving away from that other
kinds of
statistical uh visualizations subway
maps to document deportation um uh
practices making event triggered audio
video where you can add events onto
audio video visualization of Tibetan
Buddhist sex and so forth and so
on sorry about that music um okay so now
I've run out of time so I'm going to
wrap up in like 120 seconds really
quickly I won't tell you about
collaborating but we spend a lot of time
on the learning management system um in
order to try to help faculty use the
learning management system not simply
for their classes but as a tool for
collaboration and so we have spent a lot
of time working with Central it to
basically bundle in these applications
into our learning management system so
instead of having to manage like like
what group of people and what roles do I
want to have them uh have in in Shiva
for visualization or for the media base
for audio video it's all managed by the
Learning Management System you make one
group in your learning management system
and you can say that group can have
access to these visualization practices
it can have access to this Audio Video
Collection and so forth so we really
believed in the kind of economy of
saying one way to sign on one password
and One login we use shith one way to
form groups one way to assign roles and
yet a broad diversity of applications
that have nothing inherently to do with
each other that's what a digital ecology
is and then we've been working with
WordPress and Drupal in terms of
creating a publishing system and those
are just all kind of technical details
but we in the same way when Drupal is
our content management system we don't
want people just to use Drupal so we
integrate all this other stuff into
Drupal not just with embed codes but so
that you can actually have a client with
full functionality so you can access
your audio video within your Drupal
website you can build your
visualizations within your Drupal
website even though originally that
Suite of things had nothing to do with
Drupal that's the whole point of a
convergence of disperate kinds of
elements and so this is my last slide
and these are just kind of what we're
doing right now um and maybe just for
what it's worth I'll mention uh a couple
things one is the learning management
system what a debacle I mean Sakai
Moodle Blackboard and now canvas uh it's
just a complete mess in my opinion and
right now LTI is this new new standard
that's emerging as a way to take
external applications and integrate them
into your learning management system but
people are being super glib about it
they say oh here's all the LTI
integrated external applications what
they don't tell you is there's a big
Spectrum from just authentication to
lots of other functionality they're not
actually giving you so what we're doing
right now working heavily with Central
it to say you know we're not supposed to
support these as sustainable Services
we're just supposed to incubate them we
did it for 3 and A2 years we're supposed
to be engaging faculty we're supposed to
be working on data analytics and data
driven Humanities and curricular
programs and so forth and we need to get
out of supporting Drupal and WordPress
and all these other kinds of things and
Central it is not really prepared to
catch them and so we created a very
complex metric to say here's what it
means to have a scholarly service
whether it's WordPress or Drupal or
visualization at the University at any
University in terms of support needs
Hardware software Etc and who's going to
do each one of these and we're in the
process of doing that right now so we
could truly liberate ourselves from the
digital ecology and begin to work with
faculty to use it so sorry for going
over a little
bit thank you I think we have a little
time for questions um quickly I I love
the phrase um roach motel systems I
think we have a few of those of our own
um not to mention a bits of brittle Tech
here and there which I think is a common
problem um for people engaged in digital
Humanities projects
um you listed a lot of really wonderful
interesting projects even though you
we're trying to get away from a project
metaphor um so how do you determine and
I think I know some of the answers to
this some of these projects you showed
us the the The Shanti and Shiva uh what
makes them sustainable what makes them
how are you confident that they don't
become brittle Tech that they don't end
up being roach motel
systems yeah well that's a moving Target
obviously we've had 36 months so far I
think one of those things is that you
basically design things to scale for the
community I think a lot of times in
digital Humanities we're designing
things to scale for the project that it
was designed for and we had a lot of
discussion early on about how oh this
person is doing this kind of
intellectual work and so we can't have
them use the technology that someone
else is using and I just don't think
that's really true for the most part so
if we start off with thinking we're
going to design a system to deal with
audio video that deals with the majority
of needs that people have and build in
some kind of extensibility so that you
can customize it but in a way that
doesn't essentially um create an
application that at its core has been
customized so you put the extensibility
and the customization in these kind of
modular fashions that are confined to
the projects that are using them whereas
the core application is something that's
designed to be carried on and so I think
that um the designing things at at scale
in that way and then migrating them to
Central it who should really be the
groups that are running these things as
a as a university service so that's one
way in which the Shanti stuff I think is
more sustainable and more pitched to the
needs of thousands of people than what
we were doing previously so some of this
stuff comes um like you know WordPress
obviously is just out there in Drupal
and so forth some of the other things I
showed you had their provenance in
digital Humanities projects and they may
or may not end up and sustainable
technology we're trying to explore so
our idea is some of this stuff isn't
going to stick other is going to stick
but if it does stick it's got to go over
to Central it they have to be the ones
or Central it and Library Partnerships
they have to be the ones to run these as
scalable um systems with monitoring
performance metrics Disaster Recovery
all the things that you expect but until
now it's basically been about learning
management systems and learning
management systems have been pretty
impoverished at at research one
universities that's been the sustainable
scalable technology that Central it has
offered all right which is pretty
limited so it's a combination of
scalability and underlying standards so
that migration can be supported I think
I think you kind of touched at that that
along the way yeah standards of course I
should have mentioned so the other thing
is just to put out there for faculty you
know you might want it to be like this
but if you adhere to this standard the
bulk of what you're doing is going to be
carried on you can you know scale back
down the ladder or scale back up but
still offer them ways to go beyond the
standard in extensible fashion but which
they clearly recognize at this point
they're going into idiosyncratic
concerns but try to keep them to these
communal standards and try to make them
understand what the value of it is I I
know there's lots of bad analogies for
the importance of Standards but one of
the ones that always stuck with me early
on was just the the road system we know
we don't I could drive from my house to
the university in five minutes but it
would involv me going across a lot of
people's Lawns so I go down the roads
and I sto at the traffic lights and so
forth so right okay other questions from
the
audience
and again if you could introduce
yourselves uh as you start this is
Andrew hi I'm uh Andrew I'm the manager
of web operations here at the library
and I'm also the um library's Drupal
evangelist and I know in about 30
minutes I'm going to be swamped with
questions about um the things you're
talking about so how much of this stuff
has been given back to the community in
modules and things like
that
yeah um I think the thing that's nearest
to being given back to the Drupal
Community for use is the visualization
stuff we're about to release that for
the general public theoretically in
about seven days or so and once we get
through that and we make sure it doesn't
Crash and Burn and so forth when a lot
of people use it then we'll certainly
wrap that up and make it available in a
kind of modular fashion so um there's a
the zoto we have another one that's the
Drupal one of our programmers did to
kind of integrate zoto into the
bibliographical functions within Drupal
I think that's available now although
more fundamental work needs to be done
to make it really super useful so not so
much what we've done is is available in
kind of broader fashion but certainly
the intent is to put it out there and so
if anything you be interested in just
let me know and be happy to connect you
up all the stuff is easily accessible by
any programmer we give access to but
registering it formally in that kind of
open way as a separate issue I didn't
mention about University Communications
um what we've done with University
Communications is they have moved their
entire array of departmental and Center
websites in the Drupal content
management system in addition we came up
with a deal which said we would like the
departmental websites to be scholarly U
portals because everybody goes to the
departmental website they all know it
they all have access to it and so forth
and so we would like them to be able to
post the visualization the audio video
collections Etc in those departmental
websites so we worked with University
communication
to begin to integrate those modules that
we're building in Drupal for managing
audio video managing text managing
visualizations and so forth and
integrate those into the departmental
websites so faculty can just say I'm
going to sign on to my departmental
website and not only is there that
brochure that faces the world and says
we're the economics department but
there's also a big body of community
generated visualizations structured data
and other things so that the department
itself can begin to visualize itself as
a community of information producers and
have the tools and means from us that
would allow them to do that so that took
a bit of effort but University of
communications has been
wonderful going once going
twice for for those who don't know by
the way we are also migrating into
Drupal the library itself is migrating
our all our web pages into Drupal but
the university as a whole is also
converging on Drupal as a common
platform you know hence the interest uh
from from our web group but I think
there would be interest from a lot of
other parts of the university in that
those Technologies as
well yes
Ken thank you yeah just also for general
interest this is the work that those of
us who have been working on digital
Humanities projects for the past few
years have been trying to do under
something that we've called the Yale
academic comments which at the very
least is an Enterprise uh implementation
of Wordpress on campus but we've also
done a number of Drupal projects around
that as well and I had the the very
interesting experience over the past
hour to have you basically hold up a
mirror to all of the issues that we've
been facing over the past couple of
years and and recognize that we're like
one and a half to two years behind where
you are now so uh I think what is a
wonderful opportunity for us on campus
and represent it by Peter's arrival and
the work that Andrew is doing and the
work that we're doing in central it is
that we could start to converge some of
this work now and so we had even
proposed it as a Capital project for the
next year to produce what you just
presented to us
so I'm looking forward to being in
touch yeah and I would I would say too
that some of these issues are showing up
in the Yale wide it strategic planning
process that just went through its first
phase and I was involved in just a
couple of the you know 20 or 22 groups
uh that were looking at different issues
and some of the things you mentioned
like how do faculty manage their
miscellaneous of objects came up as
something that there's a real desire for
Central support for but there are real
tools for that yet so I I saw a lot of
you know familiar touches in there that
are coming up from faculty from
Librarians from technologists around the
university so I I agree we're we we're a
year or two behind at least but the same
issues are surfacing well we we'd love
to collaborate um my my kind of
eschatology is when I become my own
client yes that was the goal so the goal
like I always refuse to take on any
University responsibilities that weren't
about Tibet except now I do something
else but but um I took this on because I
felt like as a faculty member involved
with a really complex initiative
involved involving different kinds of
digital media and tools and so forth
that it couldn't happen without the
university itself creating a sustainable
environment so I thought I'll take this
position on I'll do this work I'll
create that environment and then I can
use that environment as a kind of client
so becoming one's own father parin or
something like that um and Mark you know
Turin who's now here at Yale and he and
I were involved with many of the tools
that I showed you originally through his
work in digital Himalaya and so on and
so part of that stuff is being now taken
and generalized for the University so
that I could then have a golden
parachute out and become a client of
sustainable scalable technology that
everyone forgets I was involved with
that would be my
ideal well thank you very much oh we
have one more question in
back thank you very much for sharing
that with us um
you began by U saying you were a little
grumpy about the digital Humanities and
what you talked to us about were the uh
the uh the problems the management
problems the the technical problems I'm
wondering whether if this this the only
location of your grumpiness about
digital
Humanities I I think the the problem
with digital Humanities is um as we
heard this morning you know people
Define it in many different ways but
I've been hearing about it ever since I
was at the University of Virginia and
gone through many different kind of
epics of people thinking about it first
of all it sometimes or often is
associated with a very elite level of
activity and we have these kinds of
discussions all the time who are we
trying to benefit we trying to benefit
the innovators the experimenters the
people doing really Innovative
interesting complex things will to spend
a lot of time learning how to code and
so forth or are we trying to affect the
mainstream of what faculty are doing
overall and when dig to the degree that
digital Humanities is talking about the
elite is the degree to which I get very
grumpy about it and it's still going on
like right now we have this bigger group
at the University of Virginia trying to
think about the problem of data of of
they they call it the big data but you
know whether it's big data or complex
data data analytics literacy and so
forth It's scientists Health scientists
Educators and so forth and they look at
us and they think we're just the
terminally incompetent I mean I think
when they they hear the word humanist
they think terminally incompetent
right and so and we keep arguing that
you know we don't want to just create a
data analytics program that targets the
1% or 2% or 3% who are ready to learn
how to script python or whatever it
might be and so forth we have to figure
out that ladder that ladder that starts
down here with Herman cane and a
Godfather's Pizza and scales up to
people who really want to do complex
stains in terms of cluster analysis and
and and writing their own scripts and so
forth but it's that Solution that's like
this that I think digital humanities has
really struggled with and that accounts
for my um grumpiness with it and the
other thing I think is what a lot of
people are saying is you know the word
digital Humanities it's a it's it's a
bit of an an odd way to think and a lot
of times we also have the discussion of
alt academics people in the library and
elsewhere who have an academic
background and they have serious
intellectual concerns and and I'm really
sympathetic to that I would like to see
a university that's very different from
the way in which tenur and tenure track
professors are privileged unique uh
knowledge producers I do a lot of work
with nonprofits and community- based
organizations and local communities back
in Tibet to try to create an idea that
many of us have really legitimate uh
abilities and knowledge that we need to
represent and we should have a system
that facilitates that but at the same
time digital humanities has not been
like that whether it's people in the
library or tenur faculty it's still a
very narrow Elite kind of group of
people so I'd like to shift the focus to
whatever you want to call it datadriven
Humanity or Humanities in a digital era
or people are using different kinds of
Concepts but let's tackle the basic
challenge we have in our times which is
knowledge and community and not worry so
much about the elite VI so people ask
what's the relationship of ath and
Shanti ath is is a place that I'm very
fond of it kind of reinvented me you
know broke me down into my pieces in a
digital test tube and regenerated me but
um I think ideally the relationship
would be they do that high-end
experimentation but now it's part of a
bigger communal and and kind of
institutional strategic plan for how we
mainstream uh Revolution so you still
have the high-end part but now it has
the missing part which is that communal
institutional vision and I wouldn't call
that digital Humanities I'd call it
Humanities one more are you
sure thanks I really enjoyed your talk
thanks so much for it I wanted just to
pick up on that last uh assertion you
made I don't find you grumpy at all I
find you realistic and I really love the
way you you presented uh realism in in
the vein of humorous grumpiness um I
like the way you zeroed in on a couple
very uh energetic phrasings uh rittle
wear being one of them roach motel being
another and I've been thinking about
that and just tweeted something on that
in the context of of another way of
looking at those being the end result of
a certain type of digital Humanities
computational Humanities intervention is
Skunk Works an appropriate term for the
sort of environment you're talking about
producing the sorts of rittle Weare and
roach
motels in a skunk Weare the reason why
I'm thinking of this is a group of
people who are sent out to innovate in
essence go go off the track and many
dhers feel that they are uh part of
skunk Weare
communities um or Skunk Works
communities and the intention has never
been to do anything other than innovate
and do something really different break
the mold and the fact that the things
they produce which ultimately get to be
called by by words such as tools uh the
things they produce are are taken into
General practices or at least practices
larger than the skunks work group is an
interesting sign of success because they
are roach motels because they are
brittle Weare is that a fair
characterization and if it is do you
think one could talk about this current
moment you've done such a great job of
capturing being a point where the Skunk
Works goes fully public yeah I think
that's a good way to characterize the
The Challenge and I don't think there's
anything wrong with having Skunk Works I
think it's great but the problem is and
for me really I didn't start as someone
interested in institutions and community
building and so forth I got dragged into
it because of my involvement in Tibet
and in China and so the digital
technology for me became a pathway
through which I began to think about the
problem of community formation and
organizational behavior and
institutional building and if we all did
that what a deadly place this world
would be so we need some kind of balance
between these things the people involved
in Skunk Works and the people trying to
solve those Solutions right now I think
the problem has been over the past five
so years so that major universities are
trying to struggle to figure out how do
we create the policies and the
infrastructure and the Staffing and the
reallocation of funding and so forth so
that we can have something that's a true
dynamic partner to that skunk work
experimental kind of laboratory if we
could have both of those then what a
beautiful world we would live in and
then I could stop being director of
Shanti and go back to my my my Skunk
Works lab and I always say I'm grumpy
I'll just tell you as an aside because
these days I do something totally
different which is I had a big
initiative at the University of Virginia
on contemplative sciences and so I work
a lot with health scientists medical
nursing business people and so forth and
I find myself paradoxically always the
grumpiest person in the room and it's
because everybody else just loves
meditation and yoga and since I actually
study meditation and yoga I'm a little
critical about it you
know so I always have to give these
excuse at the start and say I'm so sorry
I don't have my happy face emoi icon on
today you know so anyways that's
probably where the grumpy part comes
from thank you and uh with that we are
adjourned for an hour and then we will
reconvene